[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
round five of the Fall Classic here in
st. Louis in Group A URI cuza Bob
hammered the hammer the Ukrainian
shortens the gap to first as the leaders
have drawn group B's undisputed frontman
haha nice caboose on had to sharp
connected passers that came down like a
guillotine on Conrad Holt ground six
starts now twenty international chess
professionals compete in st. Louis as US
chess champs calm presents the second
annual fall chess Classic
[Music]
there you see executive director and
arbiter Tony rich looking over the field
here at the fall chess classic here at
the beautiful st. Louis Chess Club in
the Central West End hello come on in to
the studio Studio B welcome I'm Ben
Simon along with international master
Eric Rosen it's a beautiful day here in
st. Louis you know they say it's fall it
looks like we're getting into winter
pretty quickly a little chilly outside
today it is yeah it's getting colder but
the action is heating up inside and
we're getting to the point of the
tournament where we can start maybe
making some better predictions of who's
going to come up come out on top yes we
know the names and faces to watch and
let's get right into it here are the
standings for our masters division we
have two players at the top tied right
now Alexi drove and Alexander Linderman
with three and a half points but you can
see there are a lot of tailors actually
right behind them in this field and
we'll see what develops it's important
to note though that drave and Lenderman
are slated to play tomorrow so if the
standings hold that's gonna be
definitely a game to watch for round
seven okay so after five let's check out
the B group in the B group it's the
caboose Ian show for a few rounds now
one-point lead and then Brandon Jacobson
is his second placer now also important
to note round seven tomorrow
these two are slated to play go boos Ian
and Jacobson
so if the standings hold another clear
one and two I mean you can't get more
exciting than that that's true it's the
magical around 7:00 know you were
talking earlier about the Sinquefield
cup just a couple months ago Carlson and
Caruana plating around 7:00
so definitely around to look forward to
its lucky number
here is the tournament format for those
of you joining us for the first time
there are 210 player round robins 90
minutes for the first 40 moves and then
30 minutes is added on after that for
the remainder of the game there is a
30-second increment from move number
and it is very important to note that
the players cannot agree to a draw
before blacks thirtieth move although we
had a game end before move 30 today but
we'll talk about that a little bit later
on the tournament schedule is as follows
the games themselves begin every day at
1:00 p.m. Central Time
we come on the air two and a half hours
later so 3:30 p.m. Central time and
please note that on Thursday October
18th the grand finale everything begins
earlier because we want to have room for
playoffs if necessary there will be one
undisputed winner in each section Eric
okay so social media we're super active
I mean you are a Renaissance man of
social media Eric accept that title yeah
I try to be I faked it and so join us
not only on us chess champs comm and
YouTube and twitch but also on Twitter
use the hashtag fall chess Classic we
also will be taking your questions and
comments from our YouTube chat you've
brought a lot of fine quality chess fans
into this and so I thank you very much
for that yeah I want to thank all the
fans for watching they have a great
atmosphere in the twitch chat we have
rich twitch already using the the
hammertime emotes we have Justin Bieber
Yolo adam ak's a lot of great fans
keeping an eye on the show very nice so
here is what's going on right now in
group a the five games that are
happening well ones already ended we
have Eric Hansen versus Seth Raman
Lazaro Brazil versus Rey Robson daro
spirits vs. varoujan Akopian young
Ludwig hammer vs. Alex Lenderman and the
game it's already ended our key matchup
Eric right alexei drive in eureka who's
evolved to very highly rated players
this is a shortest game of the
tournament they ended about half hour
ago the game ended in just 20 moves now
you did mention there's a 30 move draw
rule but they ended the game so quickly
because of threefold repetition it
wasn't agreed it was simply by de facto
it was yeah if the same position occurs
three times that means players can claim
a draw regardless of whether it's before
or after move 30 so we can take a look
at how that happened I was actually
excited to see this game earlier it came
from one of my favorite openings as the
black pieces as Queens gambit declined
exchange variation where black plays a
very solid line by putting the bishop on
at five this allows white to play Queen
f3 after Bishop g6 players enter a
queenless middle game this is a position
that I have had countless times myself
in both over the board tournament chess
and online chess and I usually enjoy
playing this from black side because of
the two bishops even though box pawn
structure is a little bit damaged I
usually like these kind of quiet and
peaceful middle games where it's more
strategic rather than a tactical mess
now the player is developed relatively
normally here after b3 attempting to
restrict the Knights on d6
black played a very thematic moved
Pawnee for trying to create some
weaknesses in moist territory with pawn
a four so this prompted white to play
pawn a for himself and then the bishop
came in to b4 then after some more
development 92 block plays a slice move
Knight to c8 this is actually a very
common maneuver in the structure from
night to go to d7 to b6 to see eights
eyeing this d6 square and after just one
more move castling and Knight d6 this is
what we call a Casablanca night when the
knight is combining very well with box
pawn structure basically finds a nice
place between the pawns and the knight
and the pawns work together to control
some very key center squares now going
forward here this is actually in the
moment that players began repeating
after Knight a to Bishop a3 like goes
back to c3 bishop goes back to before
looks like neither player wanted to
really deviate from this repetition and
after a few more times they shook hands
and
the game is over was there anything that
either player could have been to avoid
the draw or is this just something that
was inevitable yeah that's a good
question of course there there would be
other moves
I mean after after Bishop to b4 I would
think white might be the one wanting to
play on to try and get some positional
some positional elements going maybe a
move like pauna for to go for pawn f5
though if white plays pawn a4
immediately drops pot could respond with
pawn f5 and just close things down so
it's possible that maybe either player
could have could have played on them but
I think the players acknowledge that the
position was relatively balanced and
they didn't want to spend perhaps two to
three more hours fighting but rather
just end it early and and take somewhat
of a resting you know you get a little
bit more of a break for sure
okay so let's jump over to Group B here
are the games that are happening in our
challengers division Steven Zurich
versus Ashwin Jha ROM Brandon Jacobsen
versus conrad Holt action and reverses
danish Boros Chris u versus L Shawn more
idea body and finally our key matchup of
the day Sergey Azhar of against LaVon
Hayes go boos Ian Debussy and just being
so impressive so far starting the
tournament four and a half out of five
and a very strong section he had a very
beautiful one yesterday
beautiful grind down win against Conrad
Holt from a position which looked like a
draw but he just kept grinding kept
grinding and eventually carrying home
the full points I do want to take a look
at the current position that they have
some dust has settled I would do want to
go back there is a very interesting
moment around move 21 after white plays
rook to f3 black had to do something
incredibly awkward in this position
given the Brooke is attacking the pawn
on f7 it's not too many ways for back to
the fend the pawn Ben Simon do you see
the only black move here
you keep the pond covered well yeah you
would have to cover it cuz if you push
it to f6 that's just gonna lose weight
many attackers for love yeah well Knight
h8 looks silly 9 th aid is a very silly
looking move but that's what good is
that it had to play okay it's um it's a
bit cringe-worthy the night just going
into the corner extremely passive of all
of box pieces now on the back rink but
sometimes this is the nature of the
Berlin defence Bach just plays passively
and just tries to be solid while it's a
question of whether white can try and
break through so going forward here
white did start activating maneuver the
Knights - very active d5 square after
rook a e8 it seemed like black had
everything under control but White's
next move was just incredibly surprising
I was expecting something perhaps a bit
more positional maybe like c4 or brook
t3 but Sergei is our I've played the
incredibly fiery Brook take f7 just
seemingly sacrificing oh look but if we
look a bit further here if Knight takes
back on f7 the forks are coming Pawnee 6
is attacking the king in the Knights
after the King moves anywhere to escape
the check and that can be taken and it's
in the additional fork and white would
be completely winning in this position
now I'm a bit curious if Debussy and
missed the shot or he knowingly went
into this variation after Brooke take f7
Debussy and responded with cross a
counter fork King to e6 attacking the
knight and the rook now white is not
it's not losing any material here
because he can bail out with rook take
you seven and this is where the position
begins to liquidate after ripped a key
797 King take e7 material is actually
equal white one back upon which he had
lost earlier after f4 King e6 we have to
admire White's position white has a very
nice three-on-two majority on the Kings
side and we should note box pawns are
doubled on the Queen side this is a
one of the trademark deficiencies for
back in the Berlin opening is that box
is gonna have a much harder time
creating a cast pond on the Queen side
and my already has a very nice
well-defended passed pawn on e5 in
combination with the bishop on b2 very
nicely placed against us tonight on h8
one of the most ugly pieces I've ever
seen so I do like White's chances to
perhaps grind down this position and if
Sergei can win this game it will be good
news Ian's first loss of the tournament
we looking at for blacksmith next move
maybe Knight g6 or Knight f7 to get the
knight out of there is there anything
better I mean the the knight eventually
has to move away move towards the center
away from the corner these are the only
two legal moves when the light is in the
corner and the problem for black after
either of these moves the knight is very
much restricted by White's pawns these
pawns are actually incredibly well
placed because both f7 and g6 are light
squares the knight would then be trying
to fight for the dark squares but if we
know this all of whites pawns are
controlling dark squares so I do like
white structure here playing against
this this Knight is very restrictive and
a very maybe soon plan for white is to
simply walk the King to e4 and then just
get them rolling maybe play g4 and f5
and we can imagine that white might just
continue gating space and box going to
be the defensive for a long time to come
now remember gabbu ZN is has a one-point
lead above number two so I mean it's not
like he's gonna be derailed by a loss
here but it's definitely gonna slow him
down he's undefeated in this tournament
of course so it will be interesting to
see what happens as time progresses and
especially a good point that he could
still be in clear first even if he loses
this game yes so so how big his lead is
right okay so now that we've taken a
look at our top matchups in each section
let's see what the players are competing
for in our top division the grand prize
6,000
that's what the champions gonna walk
away with with a total prize fund of a
very generous $22,000 and our B group
$14,000 total and the winner walks away
with 4 grand and as you can see there's
hardly any losers here but you know you
want to walk away with more than the
$500
that's very true yeah it's not not bad
money for just over a week of chess yeah
okay so let's take a look in Group A at
Eric Hanson's game against Seth Roman we
have not talked to the phenomenal chess
bra yet but maybe phrase day yes yes
talk to him after his win against hammer
here the very good starts but has slowed
down since then if we take a look at the
current position I really admire white
Sabbath - very nice pawns in the center
combined with the bishop pair soccer
men's last move was pawn to f5 perhaps
trying to activate in some way maybe
even better control over the e4 square
but yeah we can imagine that okay white
has to do something about this PO
intention I would perhaps expect white
to capture on f5 maybe the knight can
capture on f5 now visually White's
position is still nice but black is
going to be looking to poke and prod
especially against these two pawns now
there is a term in chess for these pawns
on c4 and d5 these are called hanging
pawns even though they're they're pretty
well defended hanging pawns are two
pawns next to each other that don't have
any neighboring pawns on the adjacent
files so if we notice there's no pawns
on the B or e file for whites and what
this means is that one of these pawns in
this case white C pawn is somewhat of a
backwards pawn and I would imagine that
black might look to simply put a rook
eventually on c8 and maybe start
targeting the pawn if rook c8 s--
combined with ninety six complying with
d5
white is going to be on
have to be very careful here not to
allow his plans to become too weak in
this position now having some of that I
still prefer whites with the bishop hair
for the time being the pawns are well
supported and we might see we might see
some further liquidation maybe rough
taking aids rook takes Bishop might like
to drop back to f2 to restrict the
Knights and as far as white strategy
goes he wants to keep his paws supported
probably very soon activate the King and
then and probably get the pawns rolling
this is a bit reminiscent of the
position in GU Busey an azure of with as
Aras very clear nice structure and black
not really having much to play for in
terms of passports so do you think that
Eric has this one I mean it is this is
still kind of equal or do you favor Eric
significantly if I had to pick a side I
would definitely pick White's he's
definitely the one pressing for a win
here but he is lower on time he has 12
minutes just over 12 minutes left to
make about 15 moves and okay so Thurmond
is not at the board sometimes a signal
that maybe he's just relaxed maybe
getting a snack break or a coffee break
so that the pressure is on Eric to try
and maximize his assets in the position
and try and grow his advantage before he
gets too low on time I just saw a meter
over in Group B go crazy and I know
you're not using it so let's just get
your assessment here of Stephens ERK
versus Ashwin's Aram group B action
ostrich are on yeah let's take a look
let's go back a few moves now glancing
at the current position blacks blacks
tile up looks incredibly menacing with
this Queen Bishop battery and White's
King being very precarious on g2
especially with these Kings like pawns
advanced let's go back a few moves and
see how we got here seem like some of
the typical floor
structure we already see this battery
for black
I'm hu square this meeting this means
the night has always tied down to
defending h2 after 9f8 looks like black
is is beginning to optimize the pieces
and try and organize some King side
attack we can imagine that the knight
would like to come into g6 and maybe
someday i 4 also the rook would like to
come in to d8 I really like the peace
harmony for black in this position after
rook 81 96 and this prompted white to
play a seemingly very weakening move
pawn g3 now normally this move is ok to
restrict the knight on g6 also defuse
this battery but now there's a target on
g3 and it seems like Ashwin took full
advantage of that by playing a very nice
pawn break just pawn h4 really putting
the question to this pawn in g3 white
would really like to perhaps move this
pawn in h3 backwards to h2 to support
the jeep on but we all know pawns can't
move backwards and sometimes that's the
problem with pushing pawns so early is
you you make the commitment and then you
end up regretting your decisions
so this saw this provoked pawn g4 and
that's where we see ok this this
diagonal is now again open for the Queen
Bishop battery the knight hops into f4
after Bishop take out for Queen take f4
King g2 and now a very surprising move
which I'm trying to understand they
should take c4
and the first question that comes to
mind is what happens if just the Queen
takes back on c4 this looks like a
bishop which is undefended founded in
this position it's taking the bishop on
f5 doesn't do anything upon retakes
there's no now we do have an update we
have to or we have one more move played
or we do see Ashwin's rook came down
very surprising move actually rook to e3
leaving yet another so the Queen did
take on c4 the Queen did take okay for
an ostrich just heat seems to be
sacrificing all of his pieces hoping
maybe hoping maybe knowing that there is
a very strong attack coming now we see
this Knight is targeted twice on f3 by
the Queen and the rook and now the
question is what happens if the pawn
simply captures I believe the idea is
Queen to g3 going in for the check the
King would be forced back to h1 and then
after Queen take h3 Black has at least a
draw here with perpetual check this King
will have to move back and forth between
h1 and g1 and the Queen can move back
and forth between g3 and h3 now the big
question is is there anything more for
black after having sacrificed a bishop
and a rook there's not too many
attackers left to actually try and
finish off the attack so I'm wondering
if we might see a quick draw here we see
Stephen just took the rook on e3
Austrian playing very quickly Queen g3
check white has one legal move king h1
so we're seeing this playing out in real
time Queen take H 3 in this case 9 H 2
would be a disaster because of Queen h2
mates so King g1 only move and now a
play is unfolding before our eyes are we
gonna see a repetition
well you know zerks okay with it but I
wonder if Ashwin just ran out of steam
with his attack I mean did he you think
he went into this looking for the spore
straw
it's very likely I mean at this level
when you when you play a move like
Bishop takes you for you basically know
what's going to happen and we see Tony
Rich coming over putting Kings in the
son of the board so the game has ended
in a draw seems like both players
relatively content with that
you said the meter was going crazy
earlier but usually it doesn't go crazy
in these situations where it's just
threefold repetition so I think it was
an issue of me looking at some very very
preliminary analysis before you got very
deep just by chance but you can check
out the same analysis I'm looking at I'm
not really looking deep just looking at
basically meters check it out at us
chest champs calm we've got the chest 24
module live for you with the YouTube
feed embedded into it so there's nothing
like it u.s. chess champs calm click on
live it would be nice to get Stephens
irk in the studio even after a quick
draw we have not talked to him yet and
he's he's been to coming to st. Louis
many times for these high-level events
and would like to get his thoughts about
this game he was playing the white
pieces and this is yet another game this
round which ended before move 30 due to
threefold repetition a very good point
yeah yeah you can't really stop that you
can't put a rule on that it's a story
that's right okay so what else is
happening here in this round I was
looking at hammers game against
Lenderman Lenderman is one of the
leaders in group a what is going on here
we see a queen on the flank and oh a
rook on the seventh - works on a seventh
what's going on here
yeah well a white rook on c2 a black
rook on D - so it's very possible we'll
see some trades like seven about to
occur yeah
a game that I was not looking at earlier
we can go back and see how plays
developed it looks like they had some
relatively symmetrical structure the
mean and balanced in the position like
this is of course Bishop versus nights
where I might slightly prefer the Bishop
over tonight I really like the Bishop
placed on f6 staring down at White's
Queen side where all of these pieces on
the diagonal could be potential targets
also the bishop does a very good job at
keeping the black King safe going
forward here we see 94 plate maybe
attempting to play a move like Knight
take Bishop Bishop moved to e5 rook to
c1 so white does have nice coordination
with the rooks doubled on one of the
only open files after rook rook 88 seems
slightly unusual trying to understand
this move but this move maybe attempts
to do is free up this rook we could
actually imagine some possible tactics
here where black maybe would have liked
to play rook d7 with the idea of
doubling up on the D file but now I want
to put you to the test there is a very
fanatic tactic that like can play in
this position we should know this after
black's last move a rook is left
undefended you see how white can exploit
this the first thing that I'm looking at
is a is f6 I'm looking at somehow maybe
performing a check there but there'd
have to be a discover attack I know the
Queen on the fourth-ranked
am I on the right track here or am I
completely wrong all you have to be is
way more confidence okay just put the
two and two together you see the f6 you
see the check yes but you have to look
on the Queen side too and see that the
Queen is being Unleashed
to attack the undefended rook I'm
calling a eight and this would be this
would be the big problem with rook d7
leaving the a undefended Knight f6 is
just winning material for white so that
probably explains the rook a b8 move
Eric we do have Stephen Zurich ready to
be interviewed so we're gonna bring him
in here in just a moment okay well we'll
keep going with the skin and see how
they got to the current position after
pawn to b3 this is very typical when
when it is Bishop versus nice if you put
your pawns on light squares the dark
squared Bishop in this case can't really
attack to use these Queen side pawns so
there's no more perhaps ways for whites
about targets on the Queen side and I do
want to take a moment to just pause in
this position and admire white setup
everything's defended the Brooks defend
each other
rook defends a to pawn a to pawn defends
would be three pawn everything defended
on the Queen side so why does incredibly
solid here even though I did prefer kind
of the bishop for black over the Knights
it seems like a very difficult position
for a Lenderman to actually break
through or make any progress so we see
Queen a5 is plate trying to understand
this move maybe just pointing the Queen
in a safer place not allowing rook to c4
to come with tempo also putting constant
pressure against this a pawn so if white
ever moves this rock off of C 2 then the
a to pawn could be undefended so now
white actually played a very aggressive
move here pawn g4 which did not really
see coming but it actually makes a lot
of sense given that there is a potential
pawn break in the position with pawn to
g5 and if I could perhaps open the G
file and even get the Knight to g5 maybe
at some point play King H 1 in row G 1
we can see very big potential for white
to attack on the Kings side not to
mention a pawn break like g5 could be
supported with with a move like h4 so
after Queen to d5 pawn h4 was played
very unexpected attack by White's pawn
f6 drops trying to discourage this g5
break rook d2 played Queen goes back to
a5 Rick now goes to C 2 this is a sign
that white is probably playing for more
just to draw if we know this Lenderman
could have a hammer could have repeated
with rook DC - but instead plays were at
CC - after rook take D - knight take D -
and rook to e8 this brings us to the
current position we will keep an eye on
this game but I do want to go back to
the game that just finished between
Stephens irk and Austrian Jayram and
welcome to Stephens irk in the studio
good to have you here seemed like a very
quick draw today any any maybe intention
of playing for a win in this game I mean
I had intended to but he found some nice
Kings side play and I never had much
objectively and he forced the draw there
mm-hmm so I do want to go through the
game and I know Ashwin
surprised Oxshott Chandra earlier in the
tournament with an Alekhine defense so
in terms of your preparation where you
did you prepare for the Alekhine or did
you were you mostly preparing for Kuroko
which is opening that Ashwin has been
playing a lot recently so I did mostly
prepare for the Carroll but of course
had the Alekhine ready just in case I
didn't expect him to play enjoys in a
row but you never know sure I know this
variation is it has a solid reputation
for black after and I take f6 you take
f6 not the easiest line to crack months
are very strong right so how what was
your attempt to try and get the
advantage in this position so
essentially I just did a pretty slow but
principled setup my thinking is in the
long run if he doesn't have play I have
good potential for advantage in the
endgame thanks to the for v3 on the
Queen side I can try that's very true
yeah we had a Berlin going on in another
game and this is sort of similar to
Berlin situations where you have
potential to make a passed pawn on the
Queen side so going forward here I was
actually liking blacks position at some
point given that it seemed like he was
finding some nice coordination had this
very nice battery with the Queen and
Bishop were you scared at any point that
your position was maybe getting cracked
so a little bit I mean I should never
objectively have been
but I should have traded on e6 before
allowing night f8 because after night of
fate his play gets quite dangerous so
Bishop taking six and then rook takes
Rose take Lee and here's attack is much
slower I think I can just complete my
development and challenge the e-file
fair enough he would play a move maybe
like b3 or Bishop e3 should be three
Bishop d2 something like that gas seems
like a position where things could maybe
liquidate quite quickly yeah if the
rooks go off the board I would be happy
with that position because after nine FA
that seemed like a box pieces were
getting in shape and I saw this move
pawn g3 which looked quite weakening
especially after plum h4 did you see any
other like chances for him to perhaps
get a an advantage in the game so I
don't think he had a way to force the
attack through the knight on f3 is once
he plays h4 it's very hard to remove but
he could have instead of forcing the
draw transitioned into an endgame that I
think was still double-edged and can you
show us that and I take takes gj2 and
here Bishop f5 so Bishop c4 forces I
draw mhm
Bishop f5 queen of five and now Ricky
two to each threatens Queen g3 which is
crushing so I have to trade Queens
and I think we could have played this
out for a while I mean this works very
active but of course before his pawns on
the kingside are nothing to be brag
about it in a nun game that's very true
yeah it's possible if you go into a
position like this you could play out
for a few more hours and it would still
be a draw
exact so this is one of the quickest
games in the tournament we had another
quick game this round that ended in 20
moves but I think this is the second
shortest game of the tournament is this
sometimes a strategy to maybe have a
quick game to conserve energy before the
the final rounds and just have more time
to prepare so I mean that is done here
and there
admittedly I wasn't expecting a quick
draw here but I'm not going to complain
about the extra time of course if we
just see how the game ended it was
you're in the final position you're up
material but have no way to escape the
perpetual check so I do want to ask
because you you got your GM title not
too long ago you've played a lot of
norma vents in past years I played you
at least one of these events so yeah
they've had here um what are your goals
and chests now that you're a GM are you
looking to get to a straight reading
level or just play more events so some
of both I mean admittedly I think 2600
is very much within reach in the next
couple years and I have some holes in my
game I know I can work on I just want to
see what are you do you consider
yourself a full time chess professional
or do you have a job or school that
you're balancing with chess right now
full time just professional oh very nice
so I will I'll let you rest and best of
luck in your your next games thank you
thanks we're gonna take a quick
commercial break and we'll be back with
more coverage from the 2018 fall just
classic
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like ba 3
is an illegal move here because white
advances for two squares not one but it
still is something we call a song and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
gotta say clay King in seven Kingi - and
I'll try because y'all play four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length during the course of my state
yeah he told me this is that g5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think the farthest I know who
Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly will be much much more funny
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me
and what's worse I will never hear the
end of it my quality of life has just
gone downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the fall chess
classic I'm joined by another special
guest the youngest player in either
field Christopher you good to have you
Christopher in the studio now I do want
to ask you you're you're one of the only
non GM's playing in the section what is
it like playing against a high rate
player every round is it scary or you're
able to to hold your own exciting and
it's a good experience and I tend to do
well against high rated players very
nice and now you're higher either than
me actually you're you're over 2400 feet
a and you have to iron norms is that
correct so is the third norm on your
mind for this event a little bit not
that much I haven't thought about in
monstrous I'm mostly thinking about
playing good chess or making less
mistakes fair enough that's a good
that's a great mindset to have I've I've
been in your situation before and you
you always want to focus on the board
rather than the external factors now it
seem like you have a solid draw today
against Alshon more idea body who-who
was decently strong player hasn't been
feeling that well at this event but take
us through the game was this an opening
that you were expecting this King's pawn
Spanish opening yeah I mean I looked at
it but I was mostly looking at a new
line a my play against the Berlin so I
didn't look at this line down much but
it was on my radar that he might play
this but I could have looked at this
more but I decided to do what I the same
as I did like a couple days ago get
Cesaro
this modern a free line Oh a tree
so how far were you prepared in the
opening at what point where you sort of
out of your opening preparation maybe
around move 11 although I was basically
trying to remember what I have looked at
several days ago but I just decided to
think about the perdition all over again
like I hadn't prepared it just try to
find the best move fair enough and it
seems like a low risk position where
you're it seems like Weitz has just a
very solid position it's a natural play
do you feel like you were better at any
point in this game yeah so around what
point do you feel like maybe the
advantage was in your favor I mean here
a little bit but not I mean just a
slight advantage extraordinary now you
were saying just before we started this
interview that there's a key moment
around the time or you play d5 yeah I
just I think I should have played
something like c5 you can just liquid a
maybe c5 would keep the pressure in the
position given that I saw cool industry
t6
hmm and now something like we ever see
one sexy one rookie a just f3 actually
no rookie you can take some not be a oh
that's true yeah with the discovered
attacking it's the Queen and do you
success should probably just go back to
DC mm-hm
I mean and you could repeat if you
wanted to say e55 in this position and
if he faced Queenie a now takes on no
seems like a very confusing position go
back yeah just just f3 f3 just solid
solid movie sixes targets nope Edition
is better for me that seems like at some
point you'll get some slightly favorable
structure where you take on d6 and then
it's always nice when especially there's
a black pawn fixed on the dark squares
still darks for bishops on the board so
yeah maybe there are some chances to to
grind him down but I know at this level
sometimes one inaccurate move can can
lead to see full equal position now
after you play d5 did you did you miss
the fact that he could play Queenie
gates yeah and it seemed like from this
point forward after C take b-58 take b5
we weren't taking a look at this game
earlier in the broadcast but seems like
relatively balanced position as pawns
getting traded and who offered the job
did you hear me no he offered me I
thought about it a little bit but they
couldn't find anything so I decided to
accept it yeah seems like a very
reasonable decision so you've been
you've been drawing a number of games
yes some of them have been crazy like
one I was +5 the other was back in force
and I think the other one I swindled a
bad end game so the drawers have been
right yeah there's always this
reputation in chest drawers if you have
a boring reputation I know a couple of
your games of the game against the Tsar
of and again Zurich where we're very
entertaining to watch is it usually your
goal to play some more dynamic and
exciting chess against you saw players
or are you looking to just hold your own
it's hard to say I'm looking to guess
together complicated for this
I'm just looking to pay good chess fair
enough that's that's very good mindset
to have now let me ask you what's next
for you I know you're you said your home
school so you have more time to travel
and play in events like this do you have
any any big tournaments coming up I have
I think
whoa cadets coming up in November in
Spain right that's okay and any any more
Invitational tournaments where you could
potentially get Norton maybe in December
but not not really sue paradox I have
one more question for you I I was first
introduced you I seen you play in the
protest League and I know we played just
over a year ago you you playing for some
hackers right the San Jose hackers yeah
do you plan on playing the Protoss
league this year and also do you plan on
doing some more streaming commentary I
did watch some of your commentary for
the previous season I I don't know they
asked me to it's not necessarily not
necessarily I'm not sure if I want to do
it right I mind I mind
well I'm sure you still have time to
decide and of course right your focus
for now should of course be on the next
games to come so I will let you go I'll
let you rest and prepare and best of
luck in the coming rounds thank you
you're welcome
so we're gonna take another quick
commercial break and we'll be back with
more coverage from the 2018 fall chess
classic
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advised from
the best and even challenge them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
just 24 premium membership
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience may have heard about
st. Louis's world-class museums art
history science even magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
[Music]
those kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody I don't know I just I
I just have a love for the city and I've
always had a love for chess I mean it's
just it's addictive and people study it
they can see it's an unbelievable
preciseness and beauty to the things
that occur on the chessboard wanna wish
you congratulations happy birthday 10th
anniversary and wishing you another
happy 10 years to come
happy 10th anniversary to the centrist
Chester friends jelastic sander may
there be many more I want to
congratulate the Chess Club st. Louis on
10 years and hopefully many more and a
very bright future success ahead thanks
for a great first 10 years and I hope I
will continue to be playing here for the
next 10 years and a couple more decades
after that I think without the
thankfully with Jeff protecting the
United States won't really be the thing
I would like to say thank you to my
Jeanne and Rex for all they've done sort
of generosity of spirit they have is
something special and I'm very grateful
to them
it would not be an exaggeration to say
that the Chess Club and scholastic
senator Nelson Lewis changed my life and
I'm very grateful for everything it's
done for me and for chess here in the US
and around the world it's been a
wonderful ride that you've done so much
the chest thank you so much I'm
eminently grateful for what you've done
for this game and we're looking forward
to the next ten years and I wish every
wanted to continue having this amazing
fun the next I don't know century or so
all right I'm really thankful to
everyone here who has helped me at the
club Tony rich joy Bray and of course
Ruxin ginseng filled so many great
events have happened over these past ten
years that I've been involved in and I'm
looking forward to everything that will
happen in the next ten years as well so
to the future
hello chess fans and welcome back wow
it's been a while hasn't it Eric it's
been so long yeah Ben Simon here with
international master Eric Rosen for
around six action of the Fall Classic
now Eric we were looking at Eric
Hanson's game earlier with Semin and he
had what you called the hanging pawns
well he's pushed at least one of them
let's take a look at the game it's right
a lot has came off the board since we
last saw this game now there's just one
pawn on decent
and seems like Eric is in the driver
seats update the board and see how play
was progressing in this position white
white has been keeping the initiative
played Bishop to h3 hitting the rook on
c8 after Ruka fades light keeps
initiative further at Bishop to e6 check
forcing the King into the corner and now
it's Hansen to move he is taking his
time here about three and a half minutes
left to make seven more moves I do like
his chances he just has to manage his
time but it seems like white has
everything going for him past pawn
defended by the bishop and white has a
more active King too which is a very
important element element and end games
like this where you want your king
centralized in this case white can
consider just walking the King up the
board to help support the pawn maybe
maybe even help upon advance and kick
this Knight around from b6
so it is a question what to do here for
white and one of the first moves that
come to mind is a simple rook to be one
simply skewering along the B file if the
Knights
moves anywhere it's gonna leave this
pawn just undefended on b7 if Knight to
c4 we could imagine the king will walk
up though the knight could move back to
d6 defending the pawn but I would
imagine the king is happy to walk up
further perhaps to d4 first or maybe
start by taking the pawn in each seven
and then later playing King D form a
bikini 5 I like White's chances here
yeah it looks really good for Eric
Hanson what black even want to take the
h7 pawn back after that capture that you
just probably going in that life well we
we can imagine that okay let's say white
starts out by capturing on it would be
very likely that black would have to
take in a lot of these lines when white
takes on h7 the threat is actually to
flank Bishop g8 which is a very
aesthetic move but it would create a
formation where the bishop defends both
pawns and h7 plan also defends a bishop
so black would not want to allow Bishop
she ate sand almost definitely take back
on g6 now Hansen opted for a perhaps
trickier move rather than playing pawn
take pawn or rook to be one Hansen has
brought the rook to e4 I really like
this move the idea is that black cannot
take on g6 because this would allow the
H file to open and why it would have
made in one with rook age four so black
is a bit stuck here I have this move
rookie 4 it's it's both aggressive and
restrictive it prevents this light from
coming to c4 so not only does white have
ideas of putting the rook on the H file
but now I also has ideas of playing rook
to e4 attacking the knight and
controlling the c-4 square so rook d4 is
a threat to win a pawn
I would be very uncomfortable here as
black now so Thurman does have ten
minutes left so he does have some time
to perhaps calculate and figure out his
options but I I really like the the
chest bras position in this game there's
another game that in group a that caught
my eye because there is a big open file
there the C file is blown wide open and
ro spirits versus var of Cobian and I
think we should take a look at it right
now
darl just moved his queen off of the C
file over to e - what's happening here
Eric this just looks like a big mess
just like all centers all four Center
squares are occupied by something we
have to go back a few moves and see how
this is unfolding let's go back to a
quieter position maybe around here looks
like a Cobian is a one dictating play
white is moving backwards black is
moving forwards 95 attacking the bishop
on a three bishop c1 very passive move
but really the only safe Square for the
bishop given that Bach does have this
battery along the long diagonal black is
controlling these uh these two schools
these two darts where's that the bishop
would like to access so Bishop c1 trying
to stay alive after Knight to e5 black
just keeps moving forward now we see
perhaps a surprise move from lights
trying to grab space pawn to e4 we
should notice out efore is very well
supported by the Knights upon the bishop
so e4 nice attempt to perhaps try and
remove this bishop and maybe open the
position in White's favor now a Cobian
simply ignored the e4 pawn and goes
forward with his own counter play Knight
to d4 and this is where things just
start becoming a complete mess there's
so much going on here I mean this Bishop
is so attacked but now black is counter
attacking Queen attacking the knight
attacking that three pawn twice with
both nights and again this is one of
these positions which just make my head
hurt and I really pity these players for
having so loads
and having to try and navigate through
such a complex position now the Knights
kid did get traded and after Knight
takes e4 pawn take tea for this
unleashes the see file for this rook on
c8 so black is still keeping the
initiative the Queen had to move we move
to e2 the bishop dropped back to b7 so
it's interesting the bishop was attacked
to a black found some counter-attacks
for a couple moves
now finally brings the bishop to a safe
Square and now we see a very aggressive
move from white pawn f4 perhaps shifting
the momentum we saw Cobian was dictating
player but now it's white who's making
the threats trying to push this Knights
backward and if it might moves anywhere
I can imagine that white would like to
play e5 and just try and fix a pawn
structure kick the bishop on f6 I do
like f4 and that's a question of whether
black wants to move the Knights or
perhaps start by trading on a floor try
and open up the G file but white could
take back and the looming idea is not to
say the looming an idea of a 5 is still
may be present in the position now I'm
realizing that the queen is targeting
the bishop on g2 and there could be some
potential painting ideas for lack
against the g2 bishop if we imagine
Knight f7e 5 would be a tragic blunder
due to Queen take to youtube Queen takes
you to check mates so we might see that
a Cobian
would like to open the G file in this
position starting with this pollen
capture and then it'll be a question
whether white wants to take back with a
pawn or take back with the bishop but we
see a Cobian is still thinking in this
position and the time is dwindling it
means squirts has 34 seconds with the 30
second cream in this means he played his
last move with just four seconds left a
Cobian seemingly has a lot of time
compared to whites whites very low time
with with over 2 minutes left and in
such a crazy position with still a
whopping 12 moves to play we're gonna
inevitably see some fireworks happen
very soon yeah there's no chance for
perfect play here we're yeah this is
gonna you think someone's gonna make a
mistake
I mean I I prefer to be in a Cobian spot
I mean has the slight time advantage and
I I would HIGHLY expect blunders to
start unraveling especially in such a
complex position and a co pian just take
on c1 or he did just a complete surprise
given that I thought I thought the focus
was on f4 of it again we see the nature
of the counter-attack
rook takes c1 this appears to be some
kind of exchange sacrifice but if we
notice he's removing this Bishop which
was defending f4 so perhaps is like yeah
is that after rook takes backup c1 he
could take on f4 and have a very strong
attack for being down the exchange
meanwhile switz is to move I wonder how
much time he actually has on his clock
sometimes those in further there yeah
sometimes those digital clocks they get
a little bit off wow this is just a just
a back and forth of counter-attacks yeah
she's 35 he was down to 5 seconds ok and
sweets just ignored the rook on c1 and
goes along with the center play pawn
take a 5 and a Cobian has just played a
move I know if we can zoom back and see
what move was played
take five attacking the bishop and
instead of taking back on e5a Cobian
takes on d1 so this is just a complete
mess
now the rook is hanging on d1 the bishop
is hanging on at six looks like one more
move has been played now why can not
afford sellout rook take F 1 so it looks
like he took back with his rook now we
probably will see Bishop to e5 just
recapturing that's what the co Veeam has
just played and now ok a little bit bit
of dust is settling and somehow material
is almost balanced now Lackey is up upon
so I do like a cobia chances here given
that it seemed like the the tactical
variations worked out and he is he's up
upon he has the two bishops
seems like very good control in the
position but there are still some
forcing moves to be played it looks like
swear it's just crap the pawn on f5
position is opening up and it's it's
still very complex now the bishops are
staring each other these pawns are
staring each other it's a question for
black do you perhaps take on g2 first do
you take on a5 first looks like you did
take on g2 King takes you to play very
rapidly now I would expect you take a
hive see there's a couple candidate
moves there's also Queen d7 check but
that would leave the bishop undefended
so II take f5 was played
and it's very important whenever you
have a quick move in in cases where it's
just to recapture that you you play it
quickly making sure to get the most of
the 30-second increments and okay so we
it still has under a minute Cobian
keeping his time above two minutes which
is may not seem like a lot of time puts
its it's enough to perhaps avoid any any
completely careless blunders now we see
Knight to d3 has been played it seems
like White has a little bit of
compensation for being down a pawn
given that the night is very nicely
placed now on d3 blockading the pawn on
d4 also pressuring the bishop on e5
which is now attacked twice by both the
knights and the queen and we should also
notice that block is really overextended
here having pushed the pawns on f5 and
g5 it's a bit weakening to the black
king so there's there's issues that if
the bishop moves anywhere for black
there's ideas for wipe of playing Queen
to e6 check or like Bishop Bishop f6 the
Queen can start infiltrating and why
does it's getting some counter play and
this is just a heavyweight slugfest
right here it has kind of it's not as
the heart palpitations aren't as
frequent now since some of the pieces
came off the board but man that was a
crazy but we can still feel the tension
yes based on their expressions I mean
squares leaning in a Cove Ian it seemed
like he was about to make his move still
about to make his move
reaching his hand over his head but
seems hesitant seems like he's maybe not
sure of a whites counter play in this
position and now his time is ticking
down the COBE and it has actually less
time now then sweets see a Kobe in there
just taking a quick glance at the clock
always have to keep the time in your
peripheral vision making sure you're not
losing on time and there's still eight
moves to be played until they get that
additional half-hour on their clock so
should definitely stay with this game
until they make up time control
Queen d7 Chuck gating time forcing light
to somehow got out of check but that's
this doesn't really solve the problem of
this Bishop on e5 now being attached
twice and I'm not sure what the code
means it's not - if white plays just a
simple retrieving move king g1 seems
like black is still going to be under
pressure if it seems like blacks King is
a lot less safe than whites King so now
time is ticking down here first weirds
looks like there was a time update given
that version is now back over two
minutes I'm not sure how that happened
maybe the clock times aren't entirely
accurate
yeah those increments don't get at added
automatically it seems sometimes there
is a little bit of a delay so that's why
you might see sometimes the clock tick
down to zero well they're actual clocks
on the board don't say zero it's just
that there's an increment that hasn't
been added on to an hour relay so could
it happen could they actually hit zero
absolutely but most of the time you will
see it on the relay much more frequently
than it will actually happen I've had
games myself where the player well we'll
get down to one second
make their move and then they've got 30
seconds left to play so sometimes it
gets very close we see a KO being here
it retreated the Bishop to g7 and now
I'm realizing that if swear itz goes in
with a move like Queen e6 looks like
it's just a simple double attack
attacking the King attacking that five
pawn but a cobia does have a nice
defensive resource here at Queen f7
blocking the check defending the pawn
keeping everything under control and
with this resource it seems like maybe a
KO being will hold on to the pawn
advantage and perhaps be the one playing
for a win so it's did not like we knew
six and said he played rookie
eewan simply creating the battery on the
open the file I do like this move just a
simple improving of keeping the tension
sometimes cases like this especially
when light is down material the goal is
to keep the tension in the position and
make sure that things aren't coming off
the board too quickly and there's still
room for the opponents to blunder I just
got an update Eric the other Eric Eric
Hanson has just won his game against
Seth Roman we saw him making progress we
didn't really see him putting the hammer
down but yes Seth Herman has just
resigned they have just shaken hands
apparently I'm told and so we might have
Eric Hansen down here that'd be a treat
I'm sure the online audience would love
to see another Eric Eric interview in
the studio just glancing at the final
position we see that as pawn on d6 just
too strong the king is well supporting
it Claude g6 was maintained for for the
full game in South Armagh and had had
enough in this position I do want to go
back and keep an eye on the Cobian game
yeah given that still both players are
scrambling to make move 40 a time
situation both players look to be under
a minute just going back after rookie
one was played rook f8 has played
reinforcing this pawn at five no I'm I'm
perhaps fantasizing here about some day
for black playing pawn f4 maybe trying
to create a King side attack and it
could get very messy if the king side
opens up further and both Kings still
being unlike the king side and maybe
both players playing for some sort of
initiative against the pawns King
speaking of initiative we see Queen h5
was played
just targeting the pawn on d5 I do like
this move from lights just a simple a
simple attack putting the question
houses back to friendless calling it
black could play a move like h6 but this
opens up a whole in g6 perhaps flight
would be happy to jump in and just keep
constant pressure in the position so it
looks like a Cobian is a one thinking
here how to defend the pawn on d5 a move
let's played and doesn't look like you
defended the pawn actually he played
Queen a6 that's where it's very quickly
took on g5 wow this is getting this is
getting scary for both sides
the slide on d3 is undefended looks like
sweets is banking on the idea that if
the Queen takes on d3 there will be
rotating we has taken on d3 and we see
this unfolding before our eyes
expecting rookie 7 to be played very
quickly it was and then it's a question
does black have enough defense here at
least not get needed expect black to
have at least a series of checks against
the white king we should note there's
also birkoff's Aven presence in the
position now one potential outcome is if
work f7 is played white could simply
repeat moves rook e8 rook F a rookie 7
and doesn't seem like there's anything
to play for well it's like a Kobe it's
going to repeat at least once
haruka fate is the only legal move
and then we're gonna see rookie seven
I'm expecting a Cobian to think at some
point he might repeat another time or
maybe he'll start thinking here but it's
a question of whether these checks
against the king will lead to anything
because there are two potential checks
unfortunately for a black the black
queen is completely out of play
there's no way for the Queen to
immediately defend g-seven Tony a rich
walking in there and just give a Kogi in
the bottle of water I really sure what
happened maybe it was like a blueberry
yogurt maybe it wasn't a sign anyway
okay the game is continuing after okay
so after rookie seven Queen b1 has been
played the King's gonna have to walk up
whoo I see an idea here for a black the
King has to walk up to the second rank
yeah wherever it goes black can play
Queen to be two checking the King again
keeping initiative and then wherever the
King moves to again black can defend via
the long diagonal by playing pawn to d3
and I think sweets is now realizing this
sets black is not needing to go for the
repetition but rather is just holding on
to the bishop I think a Cobian is just
winning in this position if King F -
Queen B - check if the King moves back
t3 the bishops defended box just up a
piece and this deep hunt is rolling
there's one other line if rookie to that
and I mean just Queen c3 and white is
also running out of the tacit and the
rook is now just passive on me too
so let's update the board they have made
move 40 seems like squared says is going
to be taking a long think in this
position but realizing his inevitable
doom given that a Cobian house found the
way to escape this repetition and just
it should be assuming I'm not missing
anything it should be an easy win of her
for black Eric I have been informed that
Akshat Chandra has hung a piece against
Danish Boris let's take a look at this
group B game I mean we've seen
situations where plants have been
hauling butt pieces hanging that's a
different story and trying to find this
game looks like another complete mess
and a another time pressure a situation
would be nice to get a video view of the
players I want to go back and see what
is going on seems like it was a complete
mess for for many many moves now we do I
mean we have seen earlier in this
tournament that Oxshott has been having
some time management issues so perhaps
the blunder was provoked by just
spending too much time now I am counting
material here and ox are having the
white pieces is up applauded but after
Knight to e5 seemed like black is having
some very nice initiative with the night
hating the Queen on g4 in combination
with this very nice battery along that
file also this very weak f3 square given
that night can land very soon on f3 very
scary-looking outpost Queen techie 4 was
played white goes up to pawns and then I
take g5 yeah that's just a free pawn in
the center given that it's supported by
the rook and the Queen rook TC 1 a6
Bishop a4 and now Knight f3 check
I think this brings us to the current
position I'm not seeing where black is
winning material but this seems like a
very very pleasant position for lack and
seems like the momentum is just very
much shifting in the favor of of Denish
Boros who hasn't had the best results so
far but if he can score a win in this
game will be a very nice performance now
we will get back to this game but I do
want to welcome special guest Eric
Hanson in the studio good to have you
here again seemed like a very nice kind
of technical win from the opening like
very nice positional play yeah never
played this variation before but I know
that Magnus played it this year in Tata
Steel when I was commentating on that
event so I figured I need to use the
time I'm putting in I don't get a lot of
time to train these days but I'd be some
commentating so I just follow these guys
and and he went for sort of a
provocative approach I always should
note that time on offense and this is an
opening that I play as black so I was
intrigued in the morning in this game
because played very similar lines plays
a lot Enz before so I didn't have any I
just decided at the board let's try
something different maybe he prepared
against me so followed this I guess this
is sort of standard this is all very
standard and now as far as far as I
understand he 5 is one of the main moves
here is there a big difference between
playing e5 and going for anything
I guess well you just get more of an
open position by taking with d5 but I
honestly haven't checked they're just
followed Magnus and I get some sort of
small edge and I'd be happy with that
even if it's I mean in this whole
variation why it doesn't get a lot but
you get a little bit of a small push not
necessarily an advantage but you get
these active pieces that's nice bishop
on d4 and you can try to like you often
get like a slightly better opposite
bishop and game with ropes on the board
95 I think that's how their game went
and then block sometimes takes here or
at least that's the only that's all just
if I was following the game that's what
happened and then white green said
Castle and play let's say Bishop d7
queenside castle and King said queenside
castle I think that's how the game went
not much for white but did not ascend up
what you want against my lack of but
it's at least I mean you can try for a
little bit and I didn't mind I didn't
need really crazy game of course yeah
seems like a good style to play
especially if it's an annoying opening
anyways buck it's quite a bit of counter
play so although this was a good way to
try to restrict him so the reason is
provocative is the out by putting his
nights like this I always have the c4
move we're gonna pull ya c4 and I got it
and usually what's happy to open up the
bishops on double the pawns so that's
why means a little bit provocative to to
allow this maybe it's okay but I thought
I played very naturally just try to open
up for the bishop disrepair and my
pieces on the good squares I think it
was critical if we fast forward a little
bit f5 yeah after a c4 upsurge e4 was
nice first the idea of being kicking his
Bishop off of the c8 to h3 diagonals in
the future in the deep on does rolling
that Bishop will be a little offset on
g6 and then c4 and now black has
something here then has to be now
because other afterwards it felt like my
plate was pretty natural I just pull my
bishop back and push the pawns and it's
a little well very dangerous so do you
think he had any other better options
and the 96 it seemed very fun 36 I was
very happy I wasn't sure about b5 be if
I was would have spent all my time on
and the first move here is Bishop e6 and
you yell at 77 and now Bishop takes you
for if Bishop takes yeah you have to do
work this is now I have c5 so rook takes
and now we were just looking at it right
after the game this I was considering a
couple options either c5 hero rook takes
d4 rook takes e4 this should take c4
look e1 I'm threatening the background
f5 I take black can't take back because
if you take back work e5 I hit the
bishop with tempo and now I'm turning c5
and DFAS protected but instead he should
play Bishop d3 after I take on that five
and maybe box holding in this variation
because I'm gonna lose this upon far as
I know I mean there are some tricks here
for example Bishop c5 threatening rook
e8 and Rick f8 mate but he throws in
king f7 first that's a nice line I'll
just show that for the viewer is that
it's kind of unexpected meet the King
and King being attacked by the rook so
it feels like White's
you don't have enough here my one side
was one of those pawns that block its
and opposite bishops you know it starts
getting really annoying so instead
probably wasn't gonna go for this I was
gonna go for the move c5 after Bishop
takes you for sorry rook takes a 444
ever tricky for Bishop takes rook takes
c5 and now one of the critical lines is
rook takes d5
rook takes d5 rook takes e one King do
to read probably as the tract ITA
c6 and doesn't look like he's in time
yeah the sponsor c7 and rook to you just
quick enough
yeah and this is another point why the
visual on g6 is really important to kick
it off not only is it not covering it
but it can't go to f5 very easily
although now wait a sec you should be
for rook d6
so there would be maybe there should be
seven in some cases let's say you have
six seven yeah yeah it seems like
White's on the verge on the verge but it
might not be that it's the nature of
otsukare bishops I saw some variations
like this but it was getting a little
fuzzy and I was getting a lot of time so
wouldn't surprise me if there was some
one way to hold the blocky and maybe I
have to improve on on that line not sure
how I mean it's always nice to be in the
driver's seat though we're like all it
takes so maybe one inaccurate move for
the opponent to just be lost
yep and yeah it seemed like the game was
just in your favor
and what was played out ninety six and
then it's very destructive yeah I didn't
calculate Bishop g6 even those 10 things
just like take and play Bishop e6 for
example and start pushing but I thought
it was really nice to keep the bishop on
f1 and support the pawns and kiss here
let's say rook takes you one route 6147
and you see some light scrub blockades
like c5 Knight at c4 is not really ideal
for me tonight yeah I don't it doesn't
push very easily so I think they should
that phone was correct and his the back
rank is the issue because you never have
like 9 c4 rook c8 ideas because for
example yeah take on anyone let's say
first I just doesn't work so if you
can't stop the pawns then you're
definitely in trouble and so you put
have five here take getting to the back
rank now Bishop d6 rook c8 c5 take takes
94 although this was clever I knew what
he's going for because I was very
tempted rook takes e4 F takes e4 d6 I
want to play just e7 and for example
let's say P should be 8 well then I'll
play Bishop check King over and Bishop
e6 get
getting the two bishops and just in a
bind but instead he actually has the
move rook f8 here and let's say Bishop
Chuck
well now Bishop f7 I can't take because
in the Rick will take on f7 and just
block it on d7 losing and okay I can try
to yeah I'm not so boxed in time there
to get something covering d7 so
interesting it's very tempting instead I
found a nice line take on f5
I take c5 take on g6 97 shockingly to
Knight takes Bishop h3 and you get one
of these really nasty binds and this is
a 35 to 40 we're getting a long time but
I put a check the King moves and he's
just stuck pretty much forever because
even if you we don't want to take on g6
and some lines because the 8th route
might be checkmate so yeah we saw it
around here or it just seems like black
is so restricted and you have everything
under control
yeah Rick Ricky for as nice covers the
checks turns Rick h4 would be for
everything's covered and I think this is
just lost I actually after Knight c8
here wreckage for h6 maybe I'm not
supposed attack I mean I reckon he was
winning but some people would probably
just enjoy the torture here so let's say
Rick see 496 rook c7 and you just can't
move blacks just stop like this can
follow these gates you just can't move
so this might be I feel like torturing
people this this looks at some point
when the first looks fun and just some
cruel and unusual punishments just to
show how the game ended its yike I hope
he didn't have something area I just
figured this was a technical win
picking up now d6 yes push them yeah and
you just resign well I think everyone's
been on the wrong side of what your King
has just stuck with this pawn on g6 and
the rooks gonna come on the seventh and
well everything will just fall that's
right now this game reminds me of a song
that you have on Spotify this is push
and beat or something cheering Yas for
Sara Juan do you ever have that song
stuck in your mind and like a sermon I
actually don't a lot of people tell me
that they have a song stuck in their
head and they really like the song I
mean I like the song but it's not what's
playing in my head I need something a
little faster paced and I definitely
have some like techno going on or or
something that's a little little faster
I'm not sure if you Astra's voice in my
head is a good or bad thing so I try to
depends on what you're saying yes but I
did think during today's game that I
mean you got the past Ponzi you have to
do something with them of course and you
have any like future songs on the way we
didn't make it we'd love to do it I can
say that in 2019 a mom's gonna release a
rap single yeah I don't have one well I
might be contributing to the beat or
something but he's gonna be planning to
release something in 2019 so we're
definitely excited for that I'm sure
people all over the internet will be
looking forward to that one last
question I see that you have been
streaming past couple days is this just
a matter of blowing off steam just kind
of interacting with the audience or sort
of but at the same time just having
streamed for a month and it's been a
while and we set up you know a streams
studio here and I haven't really used it
even though we've had it for like five
months I've been traveling a lot so I
want to enjoy the office set up miss the
channel being away for a while and it is
a decent way to kick back and relax
especially after you
even when I lost the games I came on
stream it was just just just chill out
and yeah I can relate well there'll be a
stream tonight's probably probably I got
to keep up the not superstitious but I
got to keep up the roll right share
sweet well if you do stream maybe we can
raid or host you in this when this
broadcast ends but I will let you go and
prepare for the next games and go to
stream in thanks for joining us sure and
we will take a look at the remaining
games in play let's go and look at a
Cobian game which seems like a Cobian
has emerged victorious after after
having that very nice resource that we
saw earlier where it seemed like the
game was on the verge of being a
repetition when you saw this Rick come
to e7 the Brooks repeated for a couple
moves but then we saw a very nice
resource for Cobian if you're just
joining us and you want a nice puzzle I
would encourage you to perhaps pause it
here and find the very nice resource for
black Queen to be one was played King g2
and Queen B to check and then after King
to h3d three black was able to hold on
to the extra piece keep the King safe
and then the rest of the game seemed
very much one-sided black finishing
things off in decisive fashion so I do
want to welcome back Ben Simon to the
studio any news for us any any more
developments in either group well
there's only three games left and the
game that actually is is looking really
tilt toward born one player is hammer
versus Lenderman I'd recommend looking
at that before we before we end the
broadcast today let's do it see amazing
king power by the hammer for white in
this position I'll try and bring up the
board here shortly now
you know hammers trying to get back in
this thing
he again Slenderman one of the top dogs
in this section you know Lenderman
tomorrow is facing off against dre of in
battle of leaders but if hammer has his
way in this game it looks like he might
then maybe a little wrench is thrown
into our preview for the inevitable key
matchup tomorrow
well it's very true I mean I I would
really like to get the board up to show
the viewers we take a look at hammers
King just in the heart of thundermans
territory and it seems like the black
rook the black bishop completely out of
play and seems like white is actually
formulating a checkmating attack given
that there's immediate amazing mating
ideas with rook to c8 followed by Knight
g6 if the king ever moves to h7 there
will be the looming idea of the work h8
mates I don't see any defensive resource
for black in this position there has
been a move plated pawn to f5
seems like a very desperate attempt by
Linderman maybe trying to open that file
so the rook can come back into play I
would expect rook see here if the King
moves h7 this is just lost after night
g6 there's no good way to stop work h8
mates this would mean that black is
forced to play Bishop f8 and then
there's some defensive tricks because if
the knight hops into g6 right away then
black can take on and g4 unleashing the
rook and then it's white who asked me be
worried about this passage upon without
an immediate way to to checkmate the
black King on g8 so I would expect that
white can simply take on f5 and I really
like the chances for for hammer to win
in just a few more moves
because if they got to this position ing
six will land on the board you can see
Lenderman they're leaning back seems
already defeated they son based on
posture hammer very very nice posture
they are just leaning forward playing
his moves confidently and as players
developing looks like this position has
been reached he did take on five and I
would expect resignation any moment now
bye bye Lenderman let's take a closer
look at the players themselves if we get
a shot as we expect the end of this game
to come any moment
yeah rook T 2 was played in 96 I think
we might actually see ooh
rook d6 check it's actually caught me
off guard here rook t6 is almost
checkmate there's one legal move King
take e5 and now it's about time well
Lenderman keep fighting
rook f6 does defend the bishop the black
is completely paralyzed here in hammer
has an e pawn in this position earlier
with with Eric Hansen interview he was
talking about torture and it seems like
that's what we have in this position
maybe white isn't meeting right away the
lights just torturing back in this
position given that it's full domination
the bishop is stuck about fates
lunderman and hand on his head can't be
feeling too happy given that he was he
was a leader in this tournament too now
a loss will put him put him a bit behind
draya's going into tomorrow's round
right yeah he will be in second just
tied with a whole bunch of players who's
above Cobian and Hansen actually
so that will be the leaderboard going
into tomorrow
Pawnee for very nice move by hammer this
pawn on e4 is a passed pawn I would not
be surprised if he's plans just to move
the King and there we go
just handshake Lenderman he realizes his
doom it's 20 rich what's the kings in
the center of the board
very nice win by hammer yes yeah so this
is a good time to take our curtain call
for the day I think it's been a really
fun day that has decisive games three
interviews they were all really great
got to talk to Chris you everybody in
the chat loved Chris you I said we were
saying yeah I saw some very nice words
very very impressive to to handle
himself like that as a 12 year old just
very mature a lot more mature than a lot
of chess players much older than him
right let's take a look at our results
today if we have them prepared we we
have just one game going on live in
Group A and that's between burrs own and
Robson the other four games have
finished Anson with the victory hammer
with a victory and a Cobian with a
victory so Dre of and Cuza both have
drawn theirs and over in Group B we did
have four games finish already same
situation so let's take a look at what
we are looking forward to tomorrow in
round number seven in Group A so we had
a little asterisk next to one of these
games as one really to watch and it
still is it's just not clear the clear
top two and we're looking at Linderman
and Dre up there at the bottom still an
incredibly important game that maybe
could could decide this thing right and
especially with lunderman Schloss just a
couple minutes ago we can imagine that
he doesn't want to let his momentum
two months and left to regroup before
tomorrow's big game and here's the round
seven pairings for a group B and Group E
has a similar situation where we have
the two heavy hitters facing off in
Gabon and Jacobson now it's important to
note that Jacobson's game is still in
progress against Conrad Holt and the
eval says equal but anything could
happen and you know the danger of making
predictions on games before you go off
the air so we'll have to wait until
tomorrow the C now remember these games
are still going on at us chess champs
calm so if you're watching on YouTube
and on over there to us chest champs and
check out the chess 24 module Eric I'd
like to talk about really quick some
upcoming broadcasts that we have to
close out the year for 2018 the fall
chess classic we're halfway through but
our pumpkin friend is gonna transform
into a snowman soon soon enough because
it will be time for the winter chess
classic it's the same format to ten
player round robins and you will see a
different field that's coming up next
month starting November 5 at us chess
champs calm after that we have a norm
even the st. Louis Invitational still
210 player round robins but it is all
about the norms will have a grandmaster
norm field and an IM norm field and
we'll see who can walk out with a
brand-new shiny title or norm and that's
coming up starting November 16 on the
world stage we're going to see today in
chess you know the World Chess
Championship is coming up starting
November 9 in London and we will have
abbreviated coverage today in chess with
the a-team
the Superfriends yasser sarah wong Jenna
Hadi
and Maurice Ashley but that's not all
they'll be covering Magnus Carlsen
versus Cara Juana they'll also be
covering the Women's World Championship
from Russia they'll be talking about the
64 player knockout where the world
champion Jew in June it will be walking
in with no special privileges as the
incumbent
champion let's see who will walk out and
it's important to note that Sabina for
sure and Irina crush the two American
ladies will be competing in that
gigantic knockout event and then finally
we wrap up the year with the London
chest classic this year hosting the
first ever grand chest Tour Finals
Hikaru Nakamura Fabiano Cara Juana Levon
Aronian and mvl will be playing in a
four-player knockout match event you do
not want to miss this they'll be playing
classical rapid and blitz all rated by
fee day and rated by the universal
rating system and the winner of this
knockout in London will be the 2018
grand chest Tour champion and you can
get all the information at Grantchester
org that starts on December 11th and
they will have the entire broadcast for
you right down here in the wonderful st.
Louis Chess Club basement the studios
well lot to look forward to this amazing
time for chess and these later winter
months yes well we've still got three
more days of the fall chess classic
remember the games begin tomorrow at
1:00 p.m. Central but we will be on the
air two and a half hours later at 3:30
p.m. Central and if there's any super
important games from here on out you
know we're gonna stay on until the end
you know there's no I could decide cuz I
drink that Red Bull yes and they should
be paying us you should yeah well anyway
that'll do it this show was produced by
the world's greatest B team
Tammy Hyde is out today but Dennis LaRue
is our streamer you know Dennis he's one
of our youtube famous instructors Isaac
transpose graphics and audio man as
always and Dani Machuca is your
technical director for international
master Eric Rosen my name is Ben Simon
we say so long from the show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you